all right here is live
all right i hope
i'm live here
hey i've forgotten
how to do this
and b is something here says hangouts on
air is being discontinued on august the
1st for quick streaming try youtube blah
blah blah could someone please confirm
that um
i'm actually
live here you're live okay all right
first of all i forgot oh i gotta turn
off my feet
yeah so i have my ipad set up so that i
can see questions and then i'd forgotten
how to get into this thing anyway
happy to be here uh you know there was
that period of time when i was running
these regularly sort of streaming what
i'm doing i think i was learning uh
persian and arabic at the time
and then of course that was a lot of
work to do that all the time so i
stopped doing it and then people said
could you do the odd uh the uh uh you
know live streaming so i said fine so
today i want to talk about three
subjects that come up all the time
in questions from people who follow me
number one is how do you get started in
the language like you know i say listen
read listen read and people say well
yeah but i don't understand anything i
can't read anything i don't know any
words
i don't know how the language works how
can i just start listening and reading
so that's the first subject
and then since i have this opportunity
to be with people who want to ask
questions i thought i would in my
introduction here cover three topics and
then you can respond or comment or give
your opinion or ask questions about
those three
or anything else so the first thing is
like so how do you get started because
at first the language is just noise
and then the second question is
people always ask you know what do i
think of or how do i go about go about
learning more than one language at a
time
so since i have in the last little
period had that experience
with um arabic persian and now turkish
i'll talk a little bit about what i to i
do in terms of trying to maintain or
learn three languages at once by the way
it all started when i visited israel
with my wife and i put some effort into
learning learning hebrew so i can talk a
little bit about how difficult that was
to learn it from scratch then i decided
that far more people speak arabic so i
dropped my hebrew so then i'll tackle
and then from arabic i said i've learned
the script i should also learn persian
because there's so many iranians here in
vancouver so i'll talk a bit about you
know bouncing back and forth between
different languages and then the third
subject is people want to know like how
do you get talking because my emphasis
is always on
input listening and reading then at some
point you want to talk so how do you get
started talking so those are the three
subjects that i'm going to cover very
briefly just touch on and then i want to
have a sort of an exchange with uh with
all of you on that subject so
so the three subjects again are how do
you get started in a brand new language
by the way i'm not reading anything so i
can take these off how do you get
started in a brand new language second
of all how do you study more than one
language
you know two or three languages and
finally how do you then get started
speaking those are the three subjects so
insofar as getting started getting
traction in a new language
it's difficult so i can say for example
with the hebrew
i mean it goes from right to left it was
my first experience with a language that
goes right to left
you know i mean all these symbols look
more or less the same
they can be pronounced in different ways
uh
it's a real obstacle and then the sounds
of course are just just so much noise
um
it was hard and uh with hebrew we didn't
have text to speech i think
so i got myself
a little bit into hebrew found that it
was not enough when i was in israel so i
ended up speaking english russian or
french in israel
it was a real problem on a couple of
occasions for example checking out of a
parking lot when all of the instructions
on this sort of machine where you buy
your parking ticket were in hebrew 100
so i mean all i could do was try
pressing different buttons because i had
no clue what was happening
uh but then i dropped that and went into
arabic so then i go to arabic and here
again
at the beginning it's very difficult
then the
what i listen to is just noise
uh the symbols in arabic there are four
different forms of the characters and as
to how they're pronounced it can vary
you know significantly so it's not like
spanish where or even turkish where you
can read it even if you don't know what
the word is so i've now been through
this process actually it's going back to
greek
where
you know i look or you take my persian
for example i look at my mini stories in
persian and when i started mini story
one i understood nothing
nothing
and i had to read it in arabic script
but by dint of
looking up words
listening
reading listening again and if i just
looked at my statistics
on my um you know playlist where you can
see how often you listen to every item
the first five six ten lessons i listen
to them 30 40 times
and it takes that long for the brain to
get used to it you just have to as you
get into a new language where the
writing system is strange the sounds are
strange
the grammar the word order everything is
strange the brain has to get used to it
and to do that you have to
listen a lot like 20 30 times i don't
mean
listen to the same lesson over and over
and over again just staying there
because again as i said in a previous
video
repetition plus novelty so you do lesson
one few times then you go to lesson two
and then lesson three and then you go
back to lesson one
and a lot of my listening
uh is
you know i go to my course let's say the
mini stories and i say play the audio
so now i've got all 60 mini stories in a
row i don't have to go look for the
story that i want to listen to and i
find that very handy and so for the
longest time i'll start at one so
obviously one is getting listened to a
lot more than 20. but now as i'm further
along let's say in turkish i will go
down the playlist and i'll start at 25.
so i will you know each time decide
you know where i'm going to start
listening and then i go off and i clean
the garage or i uh get in the car and
then that's what i'm going to listen to
and so the answer to getting started in
a language is
you have to believe as i and i have
experienced now with with
languages with different writing systems
languages that are with which have very
little common vocabulary with with
languages that i know
and just by dent of lots of listening
and reading the language starts to
become more familiar and you just have
to trust the process and obviously with
hebrew i didn't put enough time it's not
a week or two it's not a week or two
it's it's time you have to put in that
time and and you just have and that's
it's just and you do get and it's
interesting
i was going to look out for turkish for
example
i believe the turkish book tells you to
pronounce you know if the word is for
example
is to like okay i like seven
seven okay and and so they tell you that
e is pronounced e but in fact the more
you listen to it it's closer to savarma
it's more like a ah
furthermore the r is pronounced like
almost like a ish like is in
swedish or czech or something like this
so you know
so yeah you start hearing it's different
and so you have to get used to that
because if you rely on what you read you
you end up with with a certain type of
pronunciation and at first you don't
believe what you're hearing but they're
actually not saying
they're saying
and so you have to get yourself used to
that also say in turkish the the
possessive very often is like en
or whatever you know
okay but the point is it's n and we're
used to the idea that it's his or in
chinese tada so you have different sort
of concepts of what the possessive
should be
and you can theoretically see
what the possessive is in turkish but
you just have to expose yourself to it
over and over and over again until that
becomes natural and you don't have to
think about it so the answer is how do
you get into a new language
you bite off small bits like the many
stories which is now my go-to place for
learning any language
and you just expose yourself to it and
look it up and you don't worry about
forgetting and you forget again and you
forget again and you just keep letting
the brain get exposed to it and
eventually it'll start to seem that yeah
that's how they say things so that's the
answer how do you get into a new
language lots of listening and reading
lots of repetitive listening and reading
it's not necessarily compelling content
the compelling content stage comes later
once you have a sense of the structure
of the language
which you have achieved through a lot of
repetitive listening and reading now
novelty remember then you want to seek
out interesting content and
it's very difficult at first again
because there's lots of new vocabulary
but that's what you keep on doing okay
second point was
where are we talking uh yeah balancing
different languages okay again i'm
talking about my own personal experience
we live to my mind we live in the age of
the polyglot okay
we have the ability to we can find all
kinds of language content on the
internet
uh the languages that i'm interested in
we have many stories at link there is an
abundance uh there are people who like
doing duolingo or like doing whatever
busu babel i don't know those systems
it's relatively easy to find stuff in
different languages now the next thing
is
once you are talking about learning more
than one language you are by definition
a polyglot
but
you are also by definition a dilettante
if you know the meaning of the word
delta in other words
it's one thing
if you learn a language
for work so you're an employee of a
company in japan
and you deal with uh foreign customer
suppliers whatever
partners and you have to improve your
english that's
you know one language and you're totally
focused on that language and you want to
get as as proficient as you can in the
one language very often that language is
english and typically people who learn
english aren't starting from scratch
mostly they've had a lot of english at
school and now they have to take it to
another level for
school for their job or whatever that's
dedicated get as good as i can all right
but when we're learning two or three or
four languages we are enjoying exploring
languages i don't care what i get wrong
i'm not employed by a turkish company
that expects me to put out perfect
turkish correspondence or perfect
turkish emails i'm just discovering the
language for fun so it doesn't matter
what i get wrong it doesn't matter what
i forget what matters is how much i
enjoy the process i am a dilettante and
so when on some of the comments i get
here sometimes are you know why are you
ex you know exploring all these
different languages why don't you get
really good at one
because that's what i feel like doing
that's my interest you know it's like if
you're a bird watcher why do you watch
different birds why don't you just focus
on looking at one bird well because i
prefer to look at different birds that's
all nothing more profound than that
and
it is interesting
to explore like greek and then i went to
crete a romanian and then i went to
romania but if today all of a sudden i
have to speak greek or romania can't do
it
sorry
however and similarly with persian
turkish or whatever it's an exploration
it it enables me to i watch the turkish
serials on netflix and i'm picking up
more and more of it it's fun
i have a sense of
i was in morocco speaking to the taxi
driver we were speaking
poorly but i was speaking in standard
arabic
uh i was better in persian before
chatting up the sales clerks here in
vancouver i've kind of lost it a bit
because i'm working on turkish but it's
all fine so
the question is how do you approach
studying more than one language i think
because you're a dilettante because
you're doing it for fun you do whatever
you feel like doing
i have tended to want to focus on one
language for a period of time of time so
right now my focus is turkish
and i recognize that i am sacrificing
i'm slipping in arabic and persian
so
one thing that i've started doing is
mixing back in a little bit of my
persian and arabic so i have my assimil
book
so i read the book because it's
different like my turkish learning is
predominantly on my ipad with link
heavy to the many stories and a lot of
my listening but in turkish we now have
a lot of other good sort of beginner
content i have discovered because i go
to i go to um you know my feed at link
and i can see what other people are
studying and a lot of that is good stuff
so i'm discovering other good content
but it's largely focused around
link even the netflix stuff we now have
uh
i have the ability with our browser
extension to click on a turkish movie
and i've got the whole
uh transcript the subtitles loaded in as
a lesson at link
but i don't spend most my time there i
spend most of it still on the many
stories getting a better sense of the
language
however
whatever i have put in the persian or
greek it's in my brain somewhere it's
not lost it hasn't gone down
a shoot somewhere and it's disappeared
it's there it just has to be regenerated
refreshed
and not only is it there
but because i have listened to my mini
stories so often in arabic and persian
that's almost like having taken a part
of my memory and put it in a separate
you know in a separate disk drive
somewhere so i find now that if i the
other day i have to go to the dump so i
gotta drive out to the dump with a bunch
of stuff for getting rid off and drive
back
i'm listening to my farsi
interesting first of all i hear it more
clearly than before
okay this is an experience that i've had
before if you move from language a to
language b you're forcing your brain to
learn language b when you come back to
the more familiar language a you hear it
more clearly however some words i have
forgotten but surprisingly not so many
and so because i'm going into material
that i have listened to so often i'm
able to revive it quite quickly so i can
go back to this sort of stuff that i've
learned which is in my brain somewhere i
can go find it
in my
you know storage area here which is
actually all on my ipad but nevertheless
and i can refresh myself
and so what i do then in summary is to
focus three months predominantly on one
but maybe have a few activities
in the other languages that i'm learning
persian and arabic those activities
could be reading which is a different
form of accessing the language or it
could be again listening to the mini
stories or even reading the mini stores
but kept to a very small amount so that
i'm totally focused on turkish
and by doing a little bit in these other
languages i'm also making the turkish
more
kind of new and exciting so that's kind
of how i do it but i think everyone has
to find their own way and what i do
changes as well i would say that when i
was into like going from russian to
check i just stayed 100 unchecked
uh
i didn't i didn't try three different
languages i just had one so i think we
need to explore and find out what works
best for us
third subject then is how do you start
talking so now i've had the experience
recently with greek with arabic with
persian and now with turkish i've had
like
six or seven conversations in turkish
i mean typically i like to be at least
at 300 3000 words i think
three thousand
uh and what happens is uh the first few
uh conversations and of course you can't
go and talk to perfect strangers i mean
beyond the hello how are you it's very
difficult but i can get on with the
tutor
and i i just find that i at first it's
very difficult and i find a few things
that i can say
and the good tutors they kind of bring
out the language in you they ask things
and i'm on for an hour
and i think the many stories helped me
because i've heard so many of these
phrases so often that they they start to
come out
and then of course the good tutors will
give you uh
10 15 sentences or phrases that you have
used
in the report and they will record them
and so then i study that so that my
conversation even though i'm struggling
to say things i am generating more input
around things that i try to say
and so then i study those
and that prepares me for my next
conversation
and so my first sort of foray into using
the language is typically with a tutor
call it a sheltered environment
beyond but then you know to be fair i
have
after but still after maybe 15
conversations in persian
i was having conversations with uh store
clerks here in north vancouver in uh in
persian
and uh of course the great thing with
persian is that whatever you do and
however badly you speak they are
tremendously appreciative
of your efforts
okay so those are the three subjects
that i wanted to cover and now we'll see
what sort of questions we have
um
now i'm going to start at the top here
before you start your i'd like what's
your method for memorizing russian
vocabularies from muhammad i don't
memorize vocabulary that's a very
important point i don't memorize i find
memorize it's this whole issue
of sort of block learning
versus learning and forgetting learning
and forgetting interleaving sort of
meandering learning
i find that if i do a lot of listening
and reading
and if i then read the text at link and
i will in the initial period go through
the flash cards after each page
because everything is so new to me but
after a while
just the listening and reading and
seeing words in different contexts of
course you looked them up you looked
them up each time and you looked them up
and at length they were blue and now
they're yellow and when you see the
yellow word again you still don't know
the meaning you look it up again and
maybe the next time you see it you still
don't know what it is and you look it up
again but eventually it starts to stick
so whereas trying to memorize something
i find
is
less efficient and there is research
which suggests that the sort of
deliberate block learning isn't that
effective
another 90-day challenge says someone
yeah but i'm in a way on a 90-day
challenge of my own here with turkish i
will leave it up to our link team when
they launch
um you know
when they launch the next 90 day
challenge what language are you
currently learning right now i'm focused
on
turkish
uh but kind of trying to maintain my
persian and arabic on the side
uh okay hello stevie
good morning yeah okay
uh
okay
pablo hi hey from iran okay
iran
uh
yeah i've forgotten everything but not
really
beijing okay hello from china
okay first time in the live chat huh
huge inspiration greetings from brazil
from brazil good morning
all right how to learn japanese in one
hour per day
japanese and one hour per day is gonna
be a long time
uh
you know i get in an hour a day just
listening so you have to the great thing
about listening
is not necessarily that it's it's you
know head and shoulders the best way to
learn it's just that it's so easy to do
and you can do it anywhere you are so
that without even trying you can find an
hour a day to listen
uh i listen making breakfast i listen
cleaning up after breakfast i listen in
the car i listen and whatever working
out exercising walking you name it once
you've listened no what did i listen to
so then you go and read and look up
words and i would say that you if you
can put in an hour
beyond the listening so the listening is
an hour is a freebie you got to get that
in but spend another hour reading and
learning words and in the case of
japanese learning the kanji
if you get in
say
one additional hour a day
and now i lost that where was that from
oh yeah japanese still
you know
japanese you got to put in a lot of time
so i say i always say
don't ask those kinds of questions get
to where you enjoy the process and
you'll learn as much as you learn and
whatever you learn will be good and just
go for it as long as you enjoy it
do you recommend using flashcard such as
anki because most people might recall
new words better using them while i
learned the better
emmanuel i don't do flashcards i don't
do anki uh at the early stage i do use
the flashcards in link either at an
early stage going you know from page to
page in a lesson or when i'm reviewing
anything that i have left as a yellow
link in a lesson i may sometimes rather
than rereading the lesson because don't
forget there's so much repetition in
each of those mini stories
i don't want to spend my time there it's
a question of
where do you want to spend your time do
you want to spend your time first of all
listening is the easiest thing to do and
then when i read i want to read what it
was that i listened to i don't really
want to sit there going through
flashcards so that's my choice
okay
steve
how to learn kanji reading fast
you know what
uh
two different things one i had a system
where i had flashcards that were
cardboard flash cards i still have them
here they are
and i would take
i would take these are like 50 years old
let me see if i can get one out here
and i would listen
i would uh so here's one
and i would pick it i would start out
with 10
pick out a new flash card
write it out by hand
five times
on the squared paper
then i would take the meaning or the
pronunciation and put it over three
columns then i'd pick another one and do
the same and before i had forgotten or
completely forgotten the first one i
would run into the translation or the
pronunciation and i'd write it another
10 times so this was my own
self-invented srs system i think
the characters is one area where srs
really works because it's it's a
it's so difficult to learn those and you
need to be exposed and as soon as you
learn them you forget them so i
eventually got up to 30 of these
flashcards a day and i assumed that i
was forgetting half of what i was
learning so i was constantly mixing them
back in and relearning them however i
did a lot of reading and writing
as part of my chinese learning so i was
constantly exposed to them in my reading
and in my writing so i think you have to
do a little bit of deliberate sort of
learning it can be with an srs system it
can be with a mnemonic system like
heisic
uh and mix that in with a lot of
listening and reading
okay
uh
okay so i've been through that about
kanji hi from romania
for best limbo romana forgotten most of
it okay best way to increase vocabulary
is just a lot of listening and reading
i think i'm covering the same
sort of question
over and over again gustario vero senor
phalandem
as you say uh
okay greeting from brazil blah blah blah
do you go back to listening to previous
lessons like a week ago
always go back to previous lessons but i
have no particular
it's random
it's random so i don't have a plan that
but i just at some point like very often
it's a matter of if i've gone through so
if i have my 60 mini stories i want to
plow my way through them and and so
plowing into the news stories is tough
sort of slogging so then i retreat back
to the stories i'm more familiar with
and then i push forward into a few more
news stories and then i go back to the
stories that i've already done and then
eventually i get to 60.
and then if i select you know listen to
the audios i'm off listening
then
necessarily i go back to the earlier
ones again don't forget that i listen an
hour a day at least
so i'm constantly going over old stories
and doing new stories okay wait a second
youtube will say
question is you know how many do i speak
fluently i'm going to do a video on this
subject like how many languages do you
speak how many how many languages do you
know okay i can speak i would say 11
languages
and i never i don't think when i first
started i spoke 12 languages fluently
i have these other languages that i know
some of like you know people i know
and
and it kind of goes gets worse and worse
and worse but those are languages that i
i have to invest some time into and if i
do that
i will bring them i will bring them back
up to a level where i can speak them so
i cannot maintain 20 languages
at a level of fluency at least i can
some people might be able to
uh is it true that after the age of 13
would be impossible to learn language
all right
i saw a lady on tv first of all it's not
true
because most of my languages i have
learned after the age of 13.
um but i saw a
congresswoman
in the united states interviewed on
television who i can't remember her name
but she is from india and she said that
she came to the united states at the age
of 16. she was
a hundred percent native like a hundred
percent okay so that's not true
okay so the question from natalia is
you know in learning more than one
language do you do it
uh do you do more than one a day so i
kind of covered this i focus on one
i focus on one
but because i'm afraid of slipping too
far like i'm doing turkish and i don't
want to slip too far in arabic and
persian so i do a little bit of those
others
every day but if i didn't and i went
three months on purge on turkish and
then went and did three months on
arabic you know i wouldn't have slipped
that far in my opinion so it's a matter
of what you like to do
uh you can either focus on one stream
but i think you have to at least have a
main focus you can't be doing three
languages equally during the day
at least i wouldn't find that satisfying
i'm more motivated to sort of push
forward into one language
ah
is drilling a part of your way of
learning language repeating not really i
don't deliberately
drill i don't deliberately drill
uh i tend to engage because the more
things i can do
you know as i say it starts with the
listening which is largely something
that i managed to
get into my other activities and then
the other
you know during the day and then my
other learning sort of is driven by the
listening that i do so i don't
deliberately do any drilling
uh
yeah so here again anthony garcia says
your accent won't be as good again there
are lots of exceptions but by and large
uh people who
start learning after the age of whatever
12 13
often don't have
as good an accent but it doesn't have to
be i got a last question is it fees will
learn more than one language at the same
time a cousin of mine has a burning uh
desire and learns english in german it's
probably paper yeah i mean it's
certainly possible i think it's more a
matter of what you want to do
and how you
where you want to be like it's your own
thing you learn languages as i said if
we're learning more than one language we
are dilettants so we can do whatever we
please try doing it
one way try doing it another way
see how you enjoy it okay how much
harder is it to become fluent in french
compared to spanish
um
oh first of all i skipped one thanks for
doing this what are some of your
favorite okay let me just go back here
i don't know what are some of your
favorite chinese novels well my first
chinese novel was
by lausa
uh
i can't remember
it's been so many years been 50 years
like i don't read chinese novels today
but as a part of my learning i i read
lotto
uh how much harder is it to become
fluent in french compared to spanish
well it depends what your native
language is if your native language is
english
i think well i think spanish is easier
because it's it's written the way it's
pronounced
as that's the big advantage um
other than that i think
rather than what's i don't think there's
a big difference in how easy they are i
think it's more a matter of motivation
and welcome morocco okay yeah morocco
boy did we ever enjoy
our
uh stay in morocco uh fez and we went up
to
chefchaouen and
it was very nice
um when you start listening to a new
language you listen to slow motion no i
don't i listen at regular speed however
i will say that
if i listen to our mini stories uh in
persian they're read quite slowly in
turkish the red quite quickly
i think it's an advantage to listen
slowly
especially at the beginning so if i were
to you know advise people who record our
mini stories i would ask them to read it
just a little more slowly don't just
plow through too quickly
okay when i was in enemy level i stopped
using my native language as a reference
and used only english i mean here again
this is a matter of um
what we like to do
i typically use english or french or
something that i speak very well as my
reference language i tend to want to
look things up
say if i'm looking up a word i don't
want to see
an explanation in the target language i
want to see an explanation in english
because
there is a good chance that that
explanation in the target language will
again contain words that i don't know
and then i'll spend my whole time
chasing down the meaning of the word
whereas i want that meaning of the word
quickly so i can get back to the content
that i'm reading
yeah here oh the question was what yeah
dilettante dilettante is a word from
french a dilettante is somebody who
does things for fun that doesn't get
into any great depth he's not an expert
like a dilettante is typically
in uh opposition to an expert you know
someone who goes into great depth a
dilettante stays on the surface
uh i'm trying to learn my mother's
native language but there are no
resources since it's tribal language and
there are no written records
i'm sorry i can't help you unless
uh yeah if you could find some people
who would record themselves and
transcribe then that would give you
some
uh something to use
uh i don't read any vietnamese
do you have any tips you can share yeah
well that was my answer
okay i'm currently learning french my
level is about a2b1 after almost two
years do you think it's too soon to
start learning italian can i learn them
simultaneously or should i wait more
uh if you have been at french vincent
and you are a2b1
um
to me two years to get to a2b1 that's
not a that's not very good progress to
be perfectly honest
uh so here you have a choice
either you focus on your french do a lot
of listening push yourself to listen to
more difficult content to read
again you got to read somewhere where
you have access to online dictionaries
or you're using a system like link
and to push yourself or it's possible
that you've kind of become a little
stale in your french in which case i
would go do italian and if you did
italian for three or six months i
think that when you get back to french
very quickly your french will start
progressing more quickly than it has
you'll be pushing a new sort of some new
space in your brain your language
learning skill capability will be
strengthened
and your french will gestate a bit this
is my experience there'll be that period
of benign neglect as i call it and when
you get back to your french a you'll be
more motivated to rediscover french and
b you'll learn more quickly so your call
but i wouldn't be against learning
italian if that's what you're motivated
to do
do you plan
to add thai if people will give us thai
content we'll add thai
and maybe if there's just enough demand
we could just pay people to make some
thai content the trouble is that we add
languages
because people ask for languages and
then we notice that very few people use
those languages also
like i'm finding with turkish that
there's a lot of good content that
people have provided if someone comes to
link to learn thai and there's very
little content in our library
they're disappointed and we don't like
to disappoint
our members so we want to have a
significant amount of content in any
language that we offer so if we get
enough content for thai we would
certainly add thai
do you speak vietnamese no
okay
what is the topic the topic is literally
anything but i did talk
uh about
uh how to get started in the language
how to learn more than one language at
the same time
and how to get started talking
i'm learning english when i was in the
intermediate level of english do i
stopped using my native language the
reference we had that
how long does it usually take before you
can move on from the beginner material
to the native speaker level content
good question
ideally there is that intermediate level
content because okay
in all of these languages i've been
learning here recently like greek like
arabic persian and turkish
i've spent a lot of time on the mini
stories because i want to get a better
feel for how the language works but of
course these get boring
and every time i move to authentic
content which might have been in the
case of arabic uh al jazeera podcast or
uh you know frostbite cat podcast a
persian there is some intermediate stuff
in persian persian online
uh greek i have to look for podcasts
it's it's just just a little bit too
difficult the ideal material in my
opinion is is conversations
that are then transcribed so people
speak naturally speaking when people
speak naturally they use less difficult
vocabulary
low you know more high frequency
vocabulary so you need that kind of
bridge but if i were to give you a
you know a sort of a generalization i
would say three to six months depending
on the language
where was i here
okay yeah three to six months uh
obviously like for turkish
it's gonna go faster because it's so
much easier to read
even persian is easier than arabic
because persian is kind of a related
your indo-european language in arabic
it's tough it's tough and so it can be
three months months in persian and
turkish it might be six or eight months
in arabic so there's no
general rule there
i'm doing this irish in russian irish is
frustrating to find resources but before
but focusing on mostly russian with some
irish mixed in is helping me make more
progress in both yes
we will have to study languages after
the hologram technician have no idea
what that is i'm looking forward to
hearing what your current views are on
learning multiple languages when you get
to that topic okay i've already been on
that topic greetings from ottawa yeah i
lived there for two years
uh
oh no ben asks if i can this after
listening to the mini story 40 times can
i tell a story orally without looking at
it not at all not at all however
um
i've soaked it into my memory at some
level so that when i as i'm now
reviewing them in arabic or farsi
persian i can almost anticipate what's
going to come it also helps me to read
because the arabic script is still
difficult for me to read but by no means
could i
haven't attempted it but it's not like i
could recite them without the text
i'm gonna announce how really just seven
months you seem reasonably fine okay
right what do you do
what do you
do to studying you know your schedule oh
i have no schedule i just
whatever i uh you know as i say the uh
the listening triggers that the
listening is something i can do whenever
i have the opportunity and then that
motivates me later on to sit down with
my ipad and go over
reading and linking what i listen to how
do you decide when to move on from one
language to another has that changed
more recently since being retired you
might have more time for languages yes
of course i have more time for languages
when i was working
uh you know it was simple i worked for
the government they sent me to hong kong
to learn chinese or i went to france to
study or we moved to japan
and then i was between jobs and i spent
a month learning german and then we did
a lot of business in sweden so i sort of
beefed up my swedish so there were
specific things in my life that
motivated me to learn a language now in
the last 12 13 years
whatever i feel like doing i decided
13 years ago i'm going to learn russian
why not
more or less to prove that you don't
have to spend all your time focused on
grammar even for languages that have
such complicated grammar
uh now
you know i i started in the i was going
to learn hebrew and then i felt why
hebrew i'll go to arabic and then i'm
saying oh i can read the arabic script
we have lots of you know just yeah
iranians here i'll learn
persian and then my wife is watching
netflix you know turkish soap operas so
i'll explore turkish and i'm kind of
interested now in exploring the middle
east so it's totally personal subjective
there is no particular
reason
ah
for a long time i've been avoiding your
link many stories for a long time but i
finally started to use them uh they are
great yeah the many stories have
revolution i i tell you i wish we had
another 60 mini stories i find that if
you know someone said how do you move
from sort of mini stories to that next
level
if
you know we can't keep just producing it
i paid someone to write 60 mini stories
in english and then we either had
volunteers or paid people to translate
them and record them
i think if we could have
200 mini stories with the same model
in which we translate and record i mean
that would that would again help bridge
the gap but it it
when i find other material in turkish or
in arabic which don't have the same
degree of repetition it's harder the
repetition and and the repetition is not
only repetition of vocabulary it's
repetition of the most common verbs it's
repetition of the most common
conjunctions it's repetition of the most
common structures in the language so
you're getting at the basic
nuts and bolts of how the language works
and that's starting to become natural to
you now you still have that enormous
task of acquiring the vocabulary but at
least you've got a bit of a base
and so i'm a great fan of the many
stories
uh when i was in the intermediate level
do i stop using like we've had that now
how many words do you have there what
how do many words do you think one
should know to be at the c1 level in
english
you know it's so difficult to say
because c1 you know c1 is very fluent to
be fluent you have to speak a lot so
it's not just a matter of having the
words but i would think
30 000 words
30 000 words because fluent now there
are some people who say fluent you can
be fluent on a limited vocabulary but
that's not true because fluent means you
understand movies you understand books
you are you can get into a conversation
where five or six people are talking
about a variety of subjects and you're
able to participate in that conversation
to do that you need a lot of words
that's fluency you don't have to be
perfect but you have to have that so
uh i think you need a base
20 30 000 words uh which might equate to
50 or 60 000 in a language like korean
or a slavic language
but then you also have to have a lot of
practice speaking and speaking in
meaningful conversations not in sort of
a sheltered conversation with your tutor
okay hello from background there's hi
one
one day i might learn bengali who knows
ah great judgment hi from brazil two
days ago i completed 30 days on link my
statistics show me that i know uh 12 000
words what kind of tips could you give
me to keep improving okay rather than
keep improving keep enjoying
if you keep enjoying you will keep
improving
so find books that you like movies that
you like say on netflix you can download
the transcripts
um talk to people as much as you can
which probably is more difficult in
brazil because there aren't that many
english speakers around you but the goal
is to keep enjoying if you keep enjoying
you will keep improving
how do you learn cases and languages oh
sorry
how okay from what you have felt greek
is closer
i said let's okay oh here we are from
what you have felt greek is closer to
middle eastern culture or as a language
or to european language
greek is very interesting because greek
you know ancient greek is at the base of
european culture
um you know you often hear people talk
about judeo-christian western
civilization i don't believe that
european culture is based on pagan i.e
not
judeo-christian
philosophy
political institutions thought
greek greece so greek is there
yet the words there are many words that
we recognize because we have you know
imported them into english or other
european languages
but i would say that the language itself
obviously is closer to european
languages geographically it's closer to
the middle east
uh the food is similar to middle eastern
food
but that's also true of uh
you know uh croatia serbia and so on and
so on so it's kind of there i wouldn't
like to i have i can't answer the
question but it certainly has elements
of both what's going on with croatian on
link okay we had
basically serbian done
and then we talked about and it's up
there
and then we said well are we going to
put it up in in um cyrillic or in the
latin alphabet and we decided because in
serbia apparently it's 50 50.
they use both so we decided we'd put it
up
for now
in the latin alphabet and that's where
it resides i i last time i looked we
hadn't yet put any
croatian specific content into the
croatian language slot however
the serbian language slot in the latin
alphabet is extremely close to
croatian i am told and
uh
next month is the or this month is the
long fest in montreal i'm going to study
turkish until the long fest and then i'm
going to study croatian serbia because
in september my wife and i are going to
croatia for 10 days
how do you learn cases in languages like
russian and polish
again it's
many stories are great for that i saved
phrases with different cases tagged them
for that reviewed them a little bit in
the vocabulary
looked at the explanations of course but
ultimately you have to get used to it
that it just seems natural to see those
cases to say those cases you get them
wrong and gradually you get them better
and then if you're off the language for
a while you receive as when i was
recently in ukraine
and uh actually i was on television in
ukrainian and russian and i was told
that i
wasn't all that good with my cases i
don't worry about it
oh
arabic i mean my keyboard is terrible
blah blah blah do you have
chambly i've ever heard of it what's
your opinion on the latin language yeah
we had a school for a couple of years uh
it's not something i would spend a lot
of time at but it's interesting in the
sense that
uh you can read what the old latin
romans
wrote
you know so you kind of
transport it back in time
um
okay
where are we here uh manager wallace
where are you from what's your opinion
on the latin language i forget steve how
could i listen to german audiobooks if i
simply know a hundred ways in german how
could it help me yeah and with a hundred
words in german actually you can't so
you need to work up to that
and that's where the mini stores come in
and um
again you can't listen to audiobooks for
which you don't have the e-text so for
example
uh when i was learning polish i would go
to publio.pl and i would buy audiobooks
for which i could get the ebook same
with ukrainian but before i can do that
i got to put in three or six months of
easier material
yes
thank you i have been off polish it's
there if i were to get back to it it
would take me a couple of days and i'll
take you up on your offer crystal
brazil lucky bro still you haven't seen
in a while have you ever used david
jane's goal this method i tried it and i
was able unable to maintain it it's just
not something that i'm
inclined to want to do
a lot of people like it i tried it and
couldn't keep doing it
uh
hello i have my first online lesson
greek tomorrow any tips for making the
most of uh this lesson and consequent
lessons you make every day and enjoy it
very much oh yeah no the thing is make
sure that your tutor
gives you a list of 10 or 15 phrases
words single words not so good phrases
or sentences 15
that you tried to use or you had trouble
or you didn't know
and so you get this and then ask her to
record that and then i take that and i
import it into link and i listen to that
many times and i keep that as a course
in
my
you know my courses and i have a record
in arabic or persian or any other
language of my all of my discussions
going back a year i mean in russian they
go back 10 years
and so that's part of your progress in
the language
and that's how you are able to make that
lesson you know work for you beyond the
hour that you spend other than that
don't worry about it
it's up to your tutor to get you talking
uh
yeah enjoy it
that's all i can say what were your
results so it says hello i'm from
bangladesh i'm learning filipino to
connect with family roots but that let
me not only how do you recommend
incorporating relays and learning
you know it's still a matter of
listening and reading um
i don't know uh if there are online
dictionaries for tagalog but um
[Music]
i i'm sorry i haven't done that so it's
very difficult for me to say
i'm learning mandarin right now and i'm
taking a break for grammar and i'm
writing the characters a lot so it'll be
easy to recognize now what do you think
about that yeah i mean i don't really i
never learned the grammar in mandarin
because the grammar is sort of basic i
mean it's not basic but it's not
complicated it's not the grammar the
issue is lots of listening to get used
to the sounds because it's often
difficult in mandarin because there's so
many homonyms and so many words that
sound the same but different tone so
that should be the focus and the
characters and the grammar you can say
you can't make i shouldn't say that but
it's hard to make a mistake in chinese
the grammar is is
refreshingly simple best way to learn
cantonese it's the same as any other
language
we even have cantonese at link
it's the first time to share a big oh
from colombia yeah we saw some colombian
uh serials on netflix uh
blanca for example which we enjoyed
currently learning both italian and
russian i've been reading in english
sometime and now i'm able to read pretty
much any but i still can't understand tv
if you have any advice for me
okay it's hard to understand tv i lived
in japan for nine years i did business
in japanese traveled everywhere we
discussed business philosophy you name
it when i watched japanese television i
had trouble it took me about five years
to where i could understand it's just
that you're not in the situation it's
somebody else's situation
um
it's hard it's hard and and sometimes
the the dialogues and these tvs and
stuff are not natural it's hard i
wouldn't be discouraged
[Music]
how do you think would it be useful to
learn tonal language like without native
speakers starting to learn reading and
like
all right if i understand the question
i don't start with a teacher i start by
a lot of listening and reading a lot of
exposure
now i have things that i'm curious about
i have phrases that i want to use
if i have paid attention to the
pronunciation
i'll gradually get better at the
pronunciation i do look at some
resources if it's a tonal language to
kind of
confirm to me what i heard because
sometimes we hear it wrong
and i just keep listening and reading
and then at some point i want to
i want to start speaking
uh
during reading okay do you translate
vocabulary or learn through context well
i use link
but so every time i don't know a word i
look it up
[Music]
okay oh i missed that
most people the problem is translate
it's not a problem you have to translate
you have to refer to something that you
know so i translate the word but if i
listen and read enough
then the text itself starts to have
meaning directly because i've looked up
the word so often that i no longer need
to look them up and the whole thing has
meaning
any russian novels that you would
recommend for beginner i would recommend
short stories by chekhov for example
uh and then the first novel i read was
by tolstoy it was the kreutzer sonata
because unlike
war and peace or anna karenina the
kreuzer sonata is only that thick and
the great thing about russian is that
just about any book you want to find
audiobooks are available and if it's
19th century like czecho for tolstoy the
ebooks are free you can import them in
the link
ah can you please speak some turkish
okay now it's it's very difficult
um
uh okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right
that's enough uh can you please speak
sometimes my favorite chinese novel
broken brass drop bra strap i don't know
that one
uh i'm learning english my level is good
blah blah blah i feel i've stopped
learning how to improve okay
obviously when we reach a certain level
like i've often said that when you start
learning a language you have that
feeling of making a lot of progress then
you go through a long period where you
don't really think that you're making
progress and you just have to continue
because there are so many words to learn
so try to enjoy it don't worry about
whether you're making progress one of
the advantages of link is that we
actually keep track of how many hours
you listen how many words you've learned
so you can see that you are
achieving something that there are these
milestones in your learning because very
often we don't have a sense that we are
improving even if we in fact are
improving
okay native spanish speaker here english
portuguese blah blah blah love that
profile picture hahaha in focusing on
arabic persian turkish in close
proximity have you found the benefit
from the shared vocabulary absolutely
absolutely it's delightful to discover
even if their meaning is slightly
different anytime you find a what they
call a false friend but which i find
very helpful uh and and that's part of
the fun of learning the three languages
is knowing that that historically and
culturally they are connected uh and
then seeing the words that are common uh
it's it's a great sense of uh you know
discovery
how important do you think speaking is
in the world president i've been
studying this for years but rarely go
out of my way to have a conversation
that improve my meaning yeah i think
speaking is is uh i mean at some point
to become truly fluent you have to speak
a lot i have found the languages that i
speak the best i have spoken the most
um but
i mean i'm quite comfortable in russian
i make mistakes but i won't be stuck
it's not that i don't understand i i was
on television in ukraine in russia i
haven't spoken much russian so as part
of the learning process
uh i don't think it's that important
particularly at the beginning
but
i like to have some like i am enjoying
my interaction with my tutors
especially if they send me a proper
report with audio that i can listen to
it's part of my input it's part of my
learning process but ultimately
listening and reading is is the most
ultimately enjoying it is the most
important thing
so and where you have opportunity to
speak
by all means
go for it and don't worry about how you
do
uh are you able to read japanese novels
text or wait a second see how important
yeah i can read japanese novels yes
uh and i can understand japanese
audiobooks but i don't do that now how
about if you're trying to learn new
language at the same time you're trying
to revive your old foreign language well
this is for muhammad uh yeah and this is
what i explained in my intro that i'm
doing some of that now but not for
languages like romanian or greek where i
know i'm weak but with the ones that i'm
now learning so i will
focus on turkish and then
uh
maybe refresh a bit of persian and
arabic in the process
uh
hi james cook okay
can you show us any picture of you when
you were younger
well what age are you interested in um
so
you know what uh
i study no i won't get into that because
we're running out of time here uh
if you wanna if you wanna um
something about my life when i was
younger you can read my book which you
can find at my blog thelinguist.com
okay do most polyglots acquire languages
only through input-based approach i
don't think it's only but i think you
cannot acquire a language without a lot
of input because you don't have the
language in you so even if you do a lot
of speaking you have to get that
language from what other people are
saying because you don't have it within
you and to learn to become fluent you
need a lot of words those words have to
come
from somewhere else so therefore you do
rely on
input
uh
i enjoy reading novels in foreign
languages yes uh
so yeah i mean if you enjoy reading them
read them i also enjoy reading uh
nonfiction like history books try and
learn japanese at the same time as
french this is okay yes not a problem i
mean
arabic farsi and uh
turkish are very different structurally
even though they share you know 10 15
vocabulary
steve do you agree that listening is
better than listening and watching at
the same time content because when you
watch a video maybe yeah
i mean i like both it depends on what
you like doing but the listening is so
much more portable i can listen in the
car i can listen while doing other
things if i'm watching a video then i
have to be sitting there watching
both are good i wouldn't say one's
better
than okay i had this problem and i was
learning japanese and had no one to
practice what i did was download this
let me say bro bro it's kind of fun i
think hopefully we're nearing the end do
you have a video where you show how is
your daily habits or routine
okay there is no daily routine
uh
i just do what i like doing
if i'm doing the dishes if i'm in the
car i'm listening and then i'll sit down
at some point during the day and do a
bit of reading and linking
uh i can speak
people find it hard to understand them
european portuguese yeah european
portuguese
uh
keep on working get your level up to b1
and then certainly when i was learning i
found some great european portuguese
podcasts
uh
pesuale transmissible or something like
that you just have to it's just a lot of
listening a lot of listening can you
write me a quick and improvingly
speaking
find someone to speak with and do a lot
more listening and reading
do i do i speak arabic i learned it up
to a certain level and i want to go back
to it
what is the most effective to try says
uh so lauren chen needs to find uh
japanese material for academic
presentations google some subjects in
japanese and you should be able to find
something i'm sorry i can't help you i
haven't been doing that
okay we're from
holy cow
okay help with check i recommend you get
on link and import some check there's
lots of material available in check
audio techa is a good website you can
find some audiobooks and ebooks
import them into link and work on your
check
oh we're near the end here all right
there always these questions about when
do i think you should start learning a
new language the answer is when you feel
like it
uh i am also learning russian i would
say that as ukrainian is so similar you
might find yeah
blah blah blah how long have you reached
level b2 in korean
all this sort of how long does it take
how long does it take
learn to enjoy it and you will improve
uh
i saw the video you're speaking i think
you're yes i'm not a genius i sure would
like to improve my korean and i will one
day okay
we're gonna stop here thank you for
listening and
we'll do this again sometime bye for now